Bernie Sanders did a town-hall on CNN
last night I'm guessing you all watch
that
you know it's saying people say that
Bernie's followers tend to skew to one
demographic in particular I was watching
his Town Hall on CNN I thought that was
especially clear last night take a look
we're back with senator bernie sanders
uh senator we have a question from the
community leader here in washington I
hurt my lip in a vape incident am I
still covered under your health care
plan our bill covers all health care
needs all what do you think of the hazy
unfiltered New England style IPAs
nothing special about him me and a bunch
of my friends submitted like 10,000
votes for New England lobster roll in
the Lay's potato chip flavor contest but
they ended up picking that Thai sweet
chili anyway was that rigged this is an
attack on the very fundamentals of
American democracy quick what do you
think about sex robots the technology is
there and that technology will only
improve from one of my favorite podcasts
but it didn't cover dr. Carver's shave
butter will you form a Congressional
podcast ethics committee to investigate
thank you very much for raising an issue
of enormous consequence I just have one
question
you feel me bro don't get me going hey
Bernie
check out my rap I love butts butts are
great
butts are what I do not hate this is the
future of the country
hardcore